welcome to CBS this morning breaking
overnight Missouri is pushing forward
with sweeping new restrictions on
abortion that banned the procedure at
eight weeks now this comes after Alabama
became the first state in decades to
make abortion a crime in almost every
case governor kiv signed a controversial
bill calling for doctors who perform
abortions to face up to 99 years in
prison the only exception is if the
mother's life is at risk one abortion
opponent televangelist Pat Robertson
said last night the state has gone too
far
Jericka Duncan spoke to the governor
about the move to upend 46 years of
Supreme Court precedent Eureka good
morning good morning to you the Alabama
law won't take effect for another six
months and it will face extensive legal
challenges but there is growing momentum
in states across the country to
capitalize on the Supreme Court's first
solid conservative majority in decades
old human life is precious alabama
governor kiv signed the nation's most
restrictive abortion ban into law
wednesday saying it's time for the
supreme court to revisit roe versus wade
where's the money coming from to support
people who aren't ready to be mothers or
aren't financially stable to take care
of a child
you simply cannot deferred protecting
lives of unborn children because of cost
it's a law that's designed to end roe
versus wade for good CBS News legal
analyst Rickey Clements says it could be
two years until the Alabama law makes it
to the Supreme Court others will reach
the docket first you may have a
whittling away of roe long before there
would be a case that could ultimately
overturn it Cleveland says it's likely
the justices will hear at least one
abortion case by June 2020 in the middle
of the presidential campaign a number of
Democratic candidates were quick to
weigh in on the Alabama law yesterday
calling abortion a constitutional right
this is a existential fight for the
right and Liberty to control your own
body the precedent is clear
I mean yet they've decided
take away a woman's basic right to make
a decision it's nothing short of an
attack on women's basic human rights and
civil rights so far in 2019 at least 28
other states have introduced some
version of an abortion ban early this
morning the Missouri Senate passed a
heartbeat bill of its own it will now
head to the House for approval we all
hope Roe will be overturned but it's
designed the day that it is signed to go
into effect to save the lives of women
and children across this state while
states are passing some of the most
restrictive legislation the country has
seen in decades
others like New York Virginia and Kansas
are counteracting with laws protecting
abortion rights a very very divisive
issue you know the governor even
mentioned in her statement no matter
which way or how you feel about this she
recognizes that this is not enforceable
right now she alluded to that and one of
one and what she said in her statement
because she knows that this is something
that's going to face a lot of legal
challenges we've seen it before but with
this being the most restrictive that
we've seen they're expecting a fight
it's chilling for a lot of people thank
you Jericho